[Música]
Bienvenidos a nuestra primera Crónica
Ambiental de 2023 a partir de hoy
retomamos nuestro espacio semanal y lo
hacemos haciendo una revisión del
calentamiento global 2022 fue el quinto
año más caliente del que se tiene
registro en la tierra según el servicio
para cambio climático copérnicos de la
Unión Europea su más reciente reporte
del clima muestra que el año pasado fue
1,2°c más caliente que la temperatura de
la era preindustrial y por encima de eso
se ubicaron 2017 2019 y 2020 además 2016
el año más cálido del que se tiene
registro así la tierra consolida ocho
años seguidos reportando temperaturas de
un grados Celsius por encima del nivel
preindustrial y en el caso concreto de
Europa 2022 fue el segundo año más
cálido desde que se han hecho los
informes a pesar de que en 2022 tuvimos
el fenómeno de la niña por tercer año
consecutivo lo que ayuda a bajar
ligeramente las temperaturas globales
Pues los vientos en el océano Pacífico
son muy fuertes y las aguas se enfrían
por lo que aumentan las lluvias
y uno de los factores que ha aumentado
al incremento de la temperatura es la
deforestación a pesar de esto en
Indonesia están ejecutando un plan para
cambiar la capital Lo que implica talar
cientos de árboles La idea es pasarla de
yakarta en un santara en el corazón de
kalimantan la región selvática que el
país tiene en la isla de borneo la razón
es que los 10 millones de habitantes de
yakarta ya ejercen una fuerte presión
demográfica y la contaminación está por
las nubes además el 40% de la ciudad
está al nivel del mar lo que implicaría
un desastre si las aguas aumentan como
se proyecta por el calentamiento global
ante esto el gobierno quiere moverla
para la selva tropical de aquí al 2024
Pero hay oposición pues la sola
construcción de carreteras ya está
destruyendo manglares y suministros de
agua sin hablar del impacto a la fauna y
flora
bajó a Kalimán tanini kalimantan es
única con sus hábitats naturales y
especies endémicas tanto
y se destruyen sus bosques de manglares
todas las especies endémicas también
desaparecerán
y las próximas generaciones sólo podrán
escuchar las historias sobre las
especies porque ya no existen en América
Latina las alertas por deforestación se
concentran en la amazonía especialmente
en Brasil y es que en diciembre del año
pasado aumentó la tala de árboles en un
150% respecto al mismo mes del 2021
según el sistema de detección de
deforestación en tiempo real del inpec
porque en 2021 se deforestaron
87,2 kilómetros En comparación con los
218,4 del 2022 así el último reporte
mensual de los tiempos del gobierno de
Jair bolsonaro hace que sea el tercer
diciembre con mayor de en los registros
recientes y aunque 218 kilómetros es un
espacio enorme que equivale a la
superficie de recife la quinta ciudad
más poblada de Brasil es un número
relativamente bajo si se compara con los
otros meses Pues de diciembre a marzo va
la temporada de lluvia y la tala aumenta
en los tiempos secos lo que sí muestra
el reporte es la tendencia del gobierno
de bolsonaro Desde 2019 cuando él asumió
la deforestación en la amazonía
incrementó progresivamente Aunque el año
pasado fue la tasa más baja con poco más
de 11.000 hectáreas de selvas destruidas
una superficie que sin embargo es igual
a la de Qatar la deforestación afecta
incluso a Panamá uno de los pocos países
del Mundo declarado como carbono
negativo nuestro corresponsal Oscar
zuluarán visitó una de las áreas
afectadas en la selva del Darién Y esto
es lo que vio
hoy si camina entre la selva Virgen a
pocos kilómetros y una reserva forestal
del Parque Nacional Darién desde hace
seis años monitorea la situación de
estos bosques algunos a punto de
desaparecer por la amenaza de la tala de
árboles en esta zona
y ahora sí estamos
estamos moviéndose
cortando los árboles ahí
primer
cuando hicimos
caminatas no estaba así después como de
tres de tres años ya ahí sí Marcos
también encontró una selva destruida
desconoce si la extracción Es legal pero
es consciente que bajo la tierra ha
quedado el cauce de una quebrada de un
devastador escenario de deforestación y
a pesar que el pueblo
ha exigido que a que le entreguen las
coordenadas de Las Maderas la área donde
que están la especie de árboles pero
ellos no han dado no han entregado Y eso
el pueblo quiere saber no para el que
sea que sea la realidad que ellos
atalaron madera en la área indicado o no
darían es considerado el pulmón vegetal
de Panamá sin embargo entre 2012 y 2019
perdió más de 20.000 hectáreas de bosque
Donald trabaja en el programa de
monitoreo de la etnianam y ha notado una
degradación importante en zonas verdes
alrededor de estas comunidades indígenas
sobre todo los últimos tres años hay un
aproximado de 18 de 1088 hectáreas aquí
a nivel nacional en los pueblos
indígenas Wow UNAM que han sido
deforestadas no y son cambios que
estamos viendo porque año tras año esto
viene sucediendo y quizás en el año que
viene va a ser una cifra más más elevada
también no Mientras estas comunidades
siguen vigilantes y tratando de
garantizar que darían siga siendo el
pulmón vegetal del istmo y las
autoridades sancionan a quienes han
cometido delitos ambientales en el lugar
comienza la cuenta regresiva para que
entre en vigencia en 2023 una ley que
obligará a todos los ciudadanos a
reconocer los derechos de la
biodiversidad en todo el país
aquí terminamos por hoy nuestra Crónica
de medio ambiente este capítulo y todos
los anteriores los pueden ver en nuestro
canal de YouTube y en nuestra página web
France 24.com nos vemos la próxima
semana para más información ambiental
[Música]